into the black position where the Knight
and the queen it's just dangerous
oh did we ever doubt Prague and his
attacking instincts this is right up his
alley Prague he loves to attack he's
played some of the most beautiful games
of the whole tour this season and the
problem for black is if you want to take
this Knight back you have to otherwise
you're just a pawn down if you take it
back your king is out in the open now
look at why it's a light Square Bishop
lined up on the same diagonal we saw a
Trader pawns the other white knight
replaces its fellow here and blacks
pawns that wall of Pawns have just
disappeared
and how the bishop has come now the
queen is going to go over to the H5
Square I mean look at Black's position
it's in tatters yeah you have an extra
pieces black you've won a knight in that
little process but what are you doing
with your extra piece nothing Black's
playing without a rook without a bishop
on that left side yeah it's all about
that black king yeah and white has too
many pieces nearby this is just textbook
classical stuff
practice clearly studied this type of
person